it's 20 years later and we see how earth
has rebuilt since the last attack and
the nations of Earth have come together
we've stopped fighting each other we've
basically been rebuilding and preparing
for a possible return of these aliens
they're coming back well she's no longer
stripper she was now a hospital
administrator she's no longer work in
that bowl and she's still taking care of
people and mainly she's mentoring her
young son and and letting him know that
it's okay for him to step in the shoes
of his father and to not be afraid and
to be your own man your father was the
bravest man I've ever seen my character
is the captain of the space Defense so I
lead a squad of elite fighter pilots
called the legacy squadron we really
took a lot of the alien technology
incorporated with our own and just make
sure that we would be as prepared as we
could be if aliens decided to try us
again we found the technology to build a
stronger and safer earth right after the
events of 1996 they made me the director
of the ESD art space Defense I spent 20
years trying to get us ready for this I
don't to give anything weight but we
meet me I have an opinion that is vetoed
early on and it turns out once again I
was right miss if they'd let a fellow
listen to me behalf found out that they
will come back because there was a
signal recorded into deep space oh my
god a distress call my character lost
his parents in
this attack and then when he was old
enough he joined the military became a
fighter pilot I was definitely bigger
than the last month I honestly had a lot
of fun on this I got to work with Jeff a
lot and he's a he's a perfect actor to
work with he's energetic he's passionate
about it he loves being at work making
movies and acting and should work with
Liam was fantastic he's just wonderful
roland emmerich is a wonderful director
he's very prepared very passionate and
playful and loves actors he gives the
act as a lot of trust and allows you to
try anything and does a lot of coverage
so we really had the freedom to do a
brilliant director and should work with
him again is great
you